e
all
I okay so what we want to do we want to
start off by looking at the side by side
oh
yeah okay good morning everybody here uh
we're ready to go ahead with this
morning's work
session some of us are
yeah okay the uh we have two bills on
the docket for this morning to discuss
uh in the work session uh both Senate
bills Senate Bill 378 which is relative
to the per performance-based School
accountability system system task force
and S SP 526 it deals with school
facility condition assessment and school
building grants for temperature control
we're going to start out with uh 378 and
I believe the committee members were
handed out a side by side on that that
was prepared by our staff upstairs and
Jen is here in the room if does
everybody have a side by side you're all
good with that yes
that's what we'll be starting up because
that takes the the current law and then
on the right hand side it goes down with
what's been proposed in the in the
Senate
Bill Jen I do not have any extra copies
of are there copies that back there on
the
table okay we may need a couple up here
on on the table up here
okay now this is a work session uh of of
our group right here um from the
Department it looks like we do have a
representative from the Department here
welcome
Caitlyn I saw your other two walk in
here a second ago and they disappeared
they were going back to doe but um let's
let's start right off with the side by
side and this is a bill that's looking
at the uh performance-based Yak up
Caitlyn School accountability system
task
force and what we can do is just walk
down through that law with the first
Roman numeral there on the side by side
which speaks to at least every four
years the commissioner shall review the
performance-based accountability system
and make recommendations for future
legislation to the legislative oversight
commission committee that's in law
that's
now now that process is being being
overhauled do you want to speak to it
Caitlyn in a little bit or do you want
us just to charge ahead sure um sure I
can talk to you talk about so the bill
that you guys have in front of you is
not intended to um not intended to
replace the existing law right now so we
have the existing laws in place this is
not a repal in place or anything like
that what we're trying to do is say that
we need continuous Improvement of the
existing law of RSA 193e and and the
pbass which is I want to remind
everybody pbass performance-based
accountability system is one of two
measurements that are supposed to ensure
that schools are providing an adequate
education and so there used to be a task
force in law that that looked at that um
the pbass measurement and refined that
and okay can you hold on just right one
second right there kitlin turn to page
570 in your statutory books
here and when you get there that's
section 193 e3-
C 570 is dealing with the
performance-based
and what Caitlyn's talking about right
now is what we changed in law four years
ago and if you look at the bottom of the
page 570 on the left hand column you can
see the historical and statutory notes
in fine
print if you go down to Roman 1 about
four lines down you can see where we had
it one point we replaced it said the
commissioner May establish a task force
to assist with this review so we've had
it there
before and it said
may but this is not law
now actually I'm talking about further
and you have the new one no this is 2016
2017 do you care to have a blue one to
look at I I don't would you like one I
got that would be helpful but um the
point that I'm trying to make is is this
is an old task force that used to be in
law said there is there is hereby
established a taskforce to develop the
performance-based accountability system
and so that's really what we're trying
to bring back is a super old task force
to kind of continuously work on that not
not the Commissioners May task force
that currently exists
can you repeat that one more time please
yes so the old the old bill so it says
there is hereby established a task force
to develop a performance-based
accountability system that beginning in
201122 school year will serve as one
method the school use to demonstrate by
the end of the school year that is
providing an opportunity for an adequate
education the commissioner shall be the
chairman of the task force and shall
appoint no fewer than nine but no more
than 13 members to the task force
consistent of Department Personnel one
or more representative educational
experts parents Guardians blah blah blah
blah so that's the old task force that
the department is that was back in the
days when Heather Gage correct and we
were changing from No Child Left Behind
to so those are separate task force so
you're talking about the federal
accountability task force which is the S
task force this is a performance-based
accountability system for the adequate
education at that time we also made
these changes right here um from what
you were reading yes that is true Mr
chair yes uh I'm I'm lost does this task
force still exist and if so no the task
force has gone out of business but
you're speaking to the task force that
used to be in business we're trying to
bring it back that's the purpose of this
bill is to bring that task force you're
referencing language in the statute that
appears on page 570 I'm trying to
understand how this relates to the
contention that the task force should be
brought back can you help me understand
what's going on with respect to the
request for the task force to be
re constituted and the language the
commissioner May establish a task force
is that what you're you're saying this
now becomes permissive under this
statute yeah as we get into our
discussion you're going to find out
what how this the the purpose for the
task force what they're going to do in
terms of looking some of the indicators
that you're looking at and determining
whether we are fiding uh the the the
assessment or the based accountability
systems working or not so do I
understand that the task force that is
referenced here on page 570 does not
currently exist that it was removed in
2020 it was removed in 2020 four years
ago okay so the task
force that the that you're
referencing um went out of business this
task force is out of business and we're
talking about reestablishing a task
force yes but there's
different the task force doesn't have to
respond back and get approval from the
legislative oversight committee as this
is written so it's taking that committee
out of the business I know it talks
about recommend but it doesn't say
approve that's the big difference so the
challenge is is that the depart the
existing pbass is in law the department
the task force anybody doesn't have the
ability to change the law without the
authority of the legislature as much as
we would enjoy that power um so that's
why the department would recommend
something to the legislature and the
legis legislature can then design a bill
or they can say no we don't like it
you're stuck with the existing law but
we don't have that ability outside of
the law right now that that's why this
task force doesn't say it will the
legislature will do something because
you already have the we don't need to
tell you that you can make laws you are
well aware that you can do that
okay let's wait on down through because
we'll have further discussion that on
page four of the side by
side where you do change the the
uh the report coming back and being
approved by the Legislative oversight
committee that I don't have side by side
so okay um I think went to get that we
went to get them represent cascaden
is it a good time to just ask a question
I mean because I I knew of this task
force before and annually the
commissioner is supposed to report out
right a summary of this accountability
system and everything is
shall and then it says the department
shall annually prepare that detail
report and then in the historical where
it does reference you just read it the
task force everything was
referencing the commissioner design
shall be the chairman of that task force
so what I'm I'm questioning now it's the
task force is not in the law currently
right was removed now that's only dated
2020 and I guess I ask why was a task
force removed from the law was it
replaced with the legislative oversight
committee or not or did they go hand in
hand but why are we going back to
something we had before that I'm
guessing
worked
um so and it makes sense but I'm just
questioning well why did it get thrown
out and we're sitting here talking about
who's going to be on a task force
doesn't make sense to me
but so I think yes I think we have a
couple different things so we we got to
remember there's essentially two
parallel but not the same accountability
systems in theory in this state y excuse
me Jen can you make sure that Caitlyn
she yeah she just
gave um so we have the need for an
accountability for an adequate for an
opportunity for an adequate education so
that is State accountability um that um
in the past schools used to be able to
prove that they are providing an
adequate education through the ibas
system the input based accountability
system or the performance-based
accountability system the department
used to um run those kind of comparisons
run the ibass I'm sure you filled it out
many times um and then if a school did
not provide inadequate or could not pro
as providing adequate education through
the ibass system then we reviewed the
pbass system right okay so that was the
past and that is still kind of the
system except that in maybe 2020 I think
it was this committee and the full
legislature changed the or to an and so
now School schools must prove that
they're providing an adequate education
through ibass and through pbass so that
was a big major change um at that same
time I think that's when the the task
force was taken out the department also
was supportive and I was part of that
supportive was um trying to tie the
state accountability system for an
adequate education to the federal
accountability system Divine designed in
the every student succeeds act um now
since we have started trying to
implement some of that we have found
that there are some challenges and we
really think that we need to look at the
opportunity for inadequate education and
the system that defines that and then
the other parallel accountability system
is the federal accountability system
that the state is required to implement
as part of the every student succeeds
act and so we're doing that with um
using all of our federal funds that we
received that we do that and we are
required to determine schools that are
Title One schools that are the bottom 5%
of schools and then we're supposed to
determine them as um CSI comprehensive
support and Improvement schools and then
provide them additional resources so
that's what we do under the federal law
the additional resources comes from the
federal
funding on the state side of things um
we started kind of going in that
direction because we said all right it's
the same assessment and we do want to
make sure that we are leveraging exist
processes as much as possible um when
we're doing this work because one we
don't have tons of extra resources to do
two two parallel um accountability
systems it's confusing why there would
be multiple accountability systems but
at the same time the opportunity for an
adequate education is not what is in the
every student succeeds act they're very
different um very different legislation
Federal legislation versus State
legislation around inadequate education
and so um a year ago when Nate and I
were here in front of you all we were
trying to say we need some flexibility
to kind of help better Define the state
accountability for an adequate education
um and then we want to leave the federal
side over here knowing that we're still
using one test we're still collecting
the same data as the same kids but
there's obviously just from discussions
with people in this room the legislature
and his a whole other people around with
like lawsuits and whatnot the the
accountability for an adequate education
is different and there are different
measurements and indicators that we
should probably be looking at rather
than outside the federal so that's
really what we're trying to do is we're
trying to kind of so back in 2020 and I
think we really starting I I think 2018
because that's why I had to grab the
2016 2017 law book we kind of co-mingled
a lot of that and we're trying now to
kind of pull some of that apart not all
of it but pull as much of it as far as
possible so we can have these two
parallel systems so we can really ensure
that we are comp with both the state's
expectations and the federal
expectations so can I represent
T thank you and I guess I want to pursue
what I kind of was talking about
yesterday that in 2017 we got rid of
pace the performance assessment the
national uh Pace Competency Based
education um and I'm wondering did it
just totally collapse I mean did did we
not have a way to measure during that
time did we not have a structure in the
state department and and now we're
trying to reconstitute something so Pace
was never about the accountability for
an adequate education it was Al it was
um assess it was Competency Based
assessments and it was different
assessment methodologies but it it never
replaced the task force it never
replaced accountability or anything like
that so Pace was an entirely separate
and it was a pilot um it was determined
by the Department of Education in
consultation with the US Department of
Education that it was something that we
could not no longer go forward with
mostly because it wasn't something that
was scalable um and so the US Department
of Education didn't approve um continu
waivers for the pace project um because
it was a pilot project it was saying
like let's see if we can TR change the
way that we are assessing kids and um it
was something that was um that we tried
and and we just decided we could not no
longer continue forward with but that
completely outside of accountability it
was never meant to Place accountability
there was no there was no talk of pace
in
accountability so let's try to get back
right to the the the uh side by side
move through it the first line in Roman
one says in current law the commissioner
shall review the performance-based
system fine then you go across to the
other side where it says there is hereby
established a task force to develop to
develop and review whereas before if you
looked at what I pointed out to at the
bottom page
570 the commissioner May establish task
force to assist with this review it
doesn't say
develop so what the department seems to
be doing here is handing off the
development which is the responsibility
of the department right now to a task
force so and the reason for that is
because we tried to do it last year and
it's very clear that this the committee
specific Ally in this room was not
supportive of the department doing that
on its own and so we said well I guess
we need a task force or we need somebody
else but we tried to change a lot of
that with 266 last year and we could not
go forward with it um there was there
was just a lot of technical concerns
that were brought up here and the
department was trying to listen to the
concerns discussed in this room um and
you know the conversation in this room
was about well what about this thing
what about this thing all you know
adding these additional indicators like
all right clearly the conversation needs
to be much bigger than just Nate green
and I trying to make an accountability
system where the math can math CU that's
really what we were trying to do last
year there's so much confusion and like
the terminology is so co-mingled and
different parts of the law are
co-mingled into here and it's as we're
trying to implement it which we've been
trying to do essentially for the last
two years for the very first time we
have really really struggled with that
because the law has just been taken and
written over over and over again and
different parts left in and different
parts removed that we really felt needed
to be there um
that I mean truly the RSA 193 c e and H
need to be completely overhauled
completely Rewritten um and we need to
make sure that we are keeping in mind
the accountability for adquate
Education the assessment requirements
that are State assessment requirements
and the Federal feral accountability
requirements for that every student
succeeds Act and the federal assessment
requirements and these are all kind of
these different buckets that um are very
important that everybody has a lot of
opinions on that are just getting a
little bit messy over times I mean we
spent an absorbant amount of time
talking about the student identifiers
last time which or the sorry the slds
system like the whole state system for
sassin numbers that's randomly
co-mingled in here it doesn't need to be
having assassin number has nothing to do
with inadequate education it's a very
important section of the law that the
department uses for a whole Myriad of
things but we really need to kind of
pull that out and that being in here
confuses everybody and so when a
superintendent or a principal comes to
us and says can you show us exactly how
in law we're supposed to be implementing
an adequate education we like oh well
here and it talks about the minimum
standards for an adequate education but
that's not the full minimum standards
section that's in the 306s that's the
minimum standards for Public School
approval there is so much confusion
that's what that's what we're trying to
fix yes represent vure thank you Mr
chair just a a question on U timing do
we do we have time to do a little bit of
amending to this or do we need to act on
this
immediately uh this bill is not an early
bill of the Senate bills we have we have
several of those and those have to be
out of committee by the 25th of this
month
these bills right here have to be out of
the here around the 14 well yeah I'm
going to say the 14th the 16th is that
Wednesday and or and we've always been
told get it out earlier so it' be about
the 14th of May this would have to come
out be acted
upon so so going down and following
where where we are with this in Roman
one
here there if you were to look at the
section I pointed to in the bottom page
also says of this task force the
commissioner shall be chair who's going
to be chair of this task force it
doesn't state in
378 um the task force would would
appoint a chair it doesn't say that so
we can it does so that would have to be
an amendment that's done to this so that
it maybe uh maybe the commissioner
appoints or maybe it's the commissioner
or maybe the you know the commissioner
opens up and then that body chooses
their chair the commissioner certainly
wouldn't have the capacity to do this
level of work um this task force to
really come up with a true
accountability system would need to meet
quite a few times for probably several
like for dayong meetings the
commissioner so the commissioner
couldn't be a chair and that's why
because the original task force too from
2016 had the commissioner as being shair
and we Nate and I specifically said
that's not something that commissioner
has the capacity to do so okay are there
any now we we were're on page one of
this side by side we were looking at
Roman one and we slipped into a starting
look at Roman two I wasn't going down
through the membership on that
particular task
force um but I was talking about who
chairs it and I know the previous laws
have always said that the commissioner
shall
chair or designate yes
correct are there any questions of
Caitlyn on one and two yes uh yeah the
thank you Mr chair the question I have I
don't
see unless I'm misreading this I don't
see any
teacher as appointed as a potential
member of this task force is there a
reason why a teacher was not I know
you've got other certified Personnel in
there but it's as you as you went
through the Litany of uh options here I
noted that there was there was not a a
practicing teacher that was involved in
this uh list here I just was there a
reason for that um I mean so teacher
could certainly fall under the category
of educational experts um so you could
certainly put a teacher in there but we
kind of felt that through principles and
superintendant that they would have the
appropriate teaching experience um
necessary to kind of cover that area too
if the committee felt a teacher should
be added we'd be fine with that too
thank you so are you going to be looking
at the Integrity um accuracy the
validity of such an instrument or
looking at some of the test and
measurement issues which we certainly
would be wanting to look at
reliability all that um Range variances
so the majority of that those kind of
questions are really handled on the
assessment side of things and there are
there's assessment there's called the
Tac it's the I don't even know what the
TAC stands for I should um but it's
essentially assessment task force that
looks at reliability and validity of of
Assessments um and so a lot of that is
handled over there on that side of
things there's no reason why this task
force couldn't but this is really about
designing what the indicators are that
the department is reviewing to determine
if a school is providing an adequate
education or not but you already put the
indicators in there so it says this say
some of the ones that we should look at
but it's I mean this these are the ones
most of these are current law right so
we said it looks like a Cherry Picked a
few okay um maybe um but so I think
these are some of the indicators that
are in current law that we said we
should look at but we should also look
at other metrics as determined by the
task force and we two weeks ago when we
sat here we had you had um I think some
people brought up CTE somebody else
brought something else up and like these
are exactly what we're saying is clearly
there's a lot of people that think there
are things that should be part of the
measurement that are not currently part
of the measurement and we need to to
determine that yesterday we spent I I'm
sorry for you taking all the time we
looked at instruction curriculum and
assessment and trying to ensure all
three are
aligned and in assessment assessment is
really an issue a topic that somebody
just can't come off the street and say
well this is what we're going to have uh
there's a lot of mechanics to it and and
as we've talked about dealing with test
and measurement stuff uh I would hope
that anything we're doing that all these
folks have a good understanding of
curriculum a good understanding of
instruction and especially when we're
talking accountability a good
understanding of test and
measurement I agree yeah okay
representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much M Davis so I I may have
missed this um uh earlier uh cuz I I I
stepped in a few minutes after you began
to uh to your test amounting but um in
the uh in the current section of
e3c what um
what types of schools does that current
the the basically the the pbass what
what schools or what organizations does
that apply to now public schools public
schools sorry uh Public District Schools
it does not apply to Charter Schools so
P say that again Public District
Schools district Public School school
district yes public school districts
okay so would it would it be fair then
to say that since it only applies to
public school districts that that the uh
the the members of the commission I'm
sorry of the task force that are that
are listed out in in um Roman 2A
B
[Music]
C A and
C um would would also be current
employees of a public school district
and and I would also add onto that what
representative Myer asked that perhaps
uh a a a a teacher holding a current
certification and currently employed at
a public school district um that that we
put those qualifiers on on um on the
members of the feels like they want to
add that that's fine I I mean I think
the old one I think might have had a
school board member
um so I mean I think just talking about
you know we've talked about including
some of the associations and things like
that those people are not employees of
school district so if the committee
wants to limit that I think that's
that's fine but right I'm just saying
cons consistent with your your your
statement that that PE only applies to
public school districts it does not
apply to Charter Schools doesn't apply
to private schools doesn't apply to efas
doesn't apply to
to those are
public those those are public school
that would apply yes that would apply to
C them but but there but there are C
Charters but there are certain things no
this doesn't apply to Charters I I
understand I can show you that where
phraseology is but I'm also looking at
the bottom page 570 where we've had this
task force in place before and I can't
understand why if we're going to have a
committee like that we don't have
educational experts on there uh why we
wouldn't have a parent on there who's
not an employee I I only was talking
about AB andc I'm not oh oh okay yeah
the where you where you go to oh you're
only talking A and C A and C which
talked about uh people with with
credentialed um um people that that are
that are serving in that capacity and
Public School District I would just say
a Schoolboard member is not probably
considered employed no but but serving
serving of a in a public school I mean I
wouldn't want a Schoolboard member while
they're on they're on the school board
of a private school um that's you know
oh okay so yeah and by are saying that's
really we metant a public school board
member we didn't need a yeah yeah I I
mean but I just want to be real this is
echoing exactly what was in the law
before and and the department okay good
what what the the have you opened up
your got it open right here 570 yeah
bottom left hand
column where it says under the under
Roman one it says 13 members to the task
force which shall consist of and then
you you read them all
that's but but that was also that was TW
was that 2020 yes yeah um I I just think
you know having being very specific
about you know the the credentials that
they hold and where they're so and and
put the certification in there require
basically requiring it I I I would just
because of the amount of time this might
actually take I think there's some
really quality retired superintendent
and principles that are maybe not
employed that we would maybe want to
cautious on that okay no and I and I was
sort of I had that in the back of my
mind I also have have in the back of my
mind um you know a teacher that that may
teach in a private school in another
state that also happens to hold a a
teaching credential in New Hampshire or
you know or something I'm I'm not sure
I'm not sure if that
if how do I
say that that that having um having
either being currently employed by a
public school or having served as an
employee in a public school in these
capacities I think is is a is is
relevant experience I agree with that
yes and that's really what the
department was trying to get with that
putting making requiring it to be a a
credential holder but it but that I
think probably what you're saying is
gets in the same direction okay and then
and then and and for the this would be a
task force so would meet in person at
the Department of Education this is not
something somebody that lives in like
North Carolina could do so yeah no I I
um but with zoom these days things yeah
and so the department is actually pretty
stringent about its requirements and
expectations of these task force members
with our accountability task force we're
very strict about that we meet in person
um we've had a few Zoom meetings but
we're really bringing it back in person
um there's a lot of value um with these
types of conversations when they're had
in person well chair lad I just served
on a task force and and there were some
Zoom meetings um you know on that been
Park too um the and and and if if I may
Mr chair just sort of continuing on
where where you've got educational
experts parents Guardians I think that's
that that there there's there's
definitely some good having parents
Guardians um in there but where where
we've got members of a public interest
group concerned with education there's a
lot of those in New Hampshire and I know
other uh U other legislation that has
called for task force in task forces or
Commissions in other areas such as um um
environmental resources things like that
have specifically called out
organizations that that have shown
tremendous commitment to the state of
New Hampshire like The Nature
Conservancy so then just say like an
environmental interest group you know
they actually specifically call out you
know uh the um you know a member
appointed by the the executive director
of of TNC uh and I'm wondering if maybe
that would apply here too because we
have a lot of um you know very serious
groups that come and testify um in this
committee so such as Nea New Hampshire
aft New Hampshire ACLU reaching higher
New Hampshire um and that possibly those
those groups could um could could have
experts contribute to this work so the
department specifically kind of put that
cash all on so we could have experts so
just kind of a couple reminders and
because this is something that NE and I
went around with like really what is the
makeup of the task force and said let's
try to tie as much to the old one as
possible
um one it's the commissioner in
consultation with the oversight
committee so I would imagine that we
would probably bring a fair number of
people as appropriate to the oversight
committee and potentially do the
appointments um so we put a cap of 15
members so that because we can't have a
500 member committee um and then so six
of them are automatically going to be
made up of superintendents from around
the state two of them are going to be
principls and one of them is going to be
a school board member so that's nine
right there so that gives you six to
kind of work with um and they could be
in that catchall category
um we absolutely value the um opinion of
a lot of the educational experts in the
state and or work with them very
regularly at the department but we
didn't necessarily want to call out each
one individually because one we just
accidentally forget somebody but two
um we want to make sure that we don't
have a gigantic task force that we we
want to make sure that's something that
we can actually control and so that's
kind of why we're saying we would
probably bring a group in consultation
and maybe say all right this is
appropriate and maybe we say if all six
of them want you know it's the if six of
them were um you know all from the
superintendent Association we' maybe say
all right well we don't want six members
of the not nhj even has six people but
we wouldn't say maybe we don't want
those six people just from that
Association because you already have six
superintendence or maybe you want to use
somebody from some of the other groups
so that's exactly kind of what the the
discussion the department inv Visions um
by you know having this task force and
having it it appointed by the
commissioner and in consultation with
the governor and this this group so and
a quick followup Mr chair on that and
when you say in consultation with the
governor and the oversight committee
what does that mean from a um from a uh
from a practical
standpoint um so the department consults
with committees I think on a regular
basis
um I think it would be we the department
really sees it as a conversation and
trying to say like all right this is who
we think is the appropriate group if you
wanted to give it more
teeth we could probably do that too um
but I also want to make sure
that we actually get a task force
appointed and move forward with
it
so further question this represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair so this task
force if I'm not understanding correctly
was in law for a number of years but
repealed in
2020 why like there must have been some
reason and is that reason still valid or
has something Chang yeah so that was
really an effort of the Department of
Education to kind of well one there was
legislation that removed a lot of old
task force everything like that so I
don't know if that was originally swept
up in that bill um I don't know if
somebody could look that up um Jen could
um but the department did try to make an
effort to consolidate a lot of the
accountability work especially with the
work that we were doing around Essa um
and then we kind of took a look at that
and said no these are really separate
systems and we really do need to pull
them apart and they do need to have
separate accountability and there's so
much that needs to go on with State
accountability and you know part of that
is the
Department's
continued learning about the systems and
the rules and how they interact with
each other um and and that's partially
through changes in laws that's partially
from the work the the department has
been doing because of the various
different funding lawsuits um the
various different bills um but so the
department was and I don't remember
exact details but probably involved with
um the elimination of the original task
force and now we're saying we really
need to pull them back apart and look at
them separately um and and a lot of that
too was is so the department when we
were trying to consolidate the
accountability um in 2017 and 18 the
department was trying to do that because
of a lot of the Essa work but now that
we have started implementing the Essa
work and we under because that was
before it was ever implemented but when
the department started doing that work
the complexity and kind of the metrics
around that were like well this is not
necessarily defining an adequate
education this is the accountability for
the federal accountability system
but the accountability for an adequate
education which is defined in RSA 193 E2
is different than what we're looking at
Nessa and part of that was conversations
too and we've had many conversations in
this committee what are you doing to
support the state schools that are not
providing inadequate education the
department does not have resources to
support those State schools if you
happen to be determined a CSI School
under the federal accountability system
and also not providing inadequate
education through either ibass or pbass
and you get lucky enough to be lucky is
maybe not the appropriate term but you
are failing under both systems you are
eligible for a very specific Federal
grant but if you are just not providing
an adequate education through ibass
alone and you're not one of those bottom
5% of schools there's nothing there's no
additional resources the department can
provide to any schools right now and
that's that's that's a challenge that
we've discussed many times because we
have say you are automatically exempt
from Federal accountability if you're
not a title one school or um have a very
very low graduation rate but so any
non-title one high school that has a
graduation rate about a above a certain
amount is automatically exempt from that
any Elementary School that doesn't
receive Title One funds which in a
district so Title One is rank ordered by
poverty um those schools are
automatically exempt from federal
accountability but those schools are
still or those towns municipalities we
as the state of New Hampshire are paying
adequate education dollars for those
kids so there should be some
accountability for those schools as well
represent
cascaden um just so I can kind of
picture this in my mind and I I Envision
that public school approval is the
following of the 306 rules correct me if
I'm wrong and the performance the
accountability that we're talking about
is the minimum standards plus the other
indicators in that accountability system
and then further the Essa accountability
plan it really encompasses all the
federal dollars and programs yeah is
that a fair way to kind of pocket these
big um it is and actually it's funny
because on the whiteboard in my office
there's there's these circles we've
talked about specifically that so um we
have a couple different things we have
the accountability for an adequate
education which is ibass and pbass so
that's kind of the inner so there's
adequate education funding there's um
the accountability for an adequate
education which is RSA 193 E2 which is a
portion of the minimum standards but not
all of the minimum standards and so
that's something that's confusing and
the department specifically tried to ter
change that terminology last year with
this committee we couldn't get there um
and so so it's a portion of the minimum
standards and then we have the minimum
standards for public school approval
which are a lot more comprehensive than
just the the ones find in RSA 193 E2 cuz
that's just a small section and that is
everything a public school has to do to
be approved and then another bubble over
here with a little bit of overlap
because the same kids the same
assessments the same you know indicators
and metrics you have Essa so there's
some overlap but there's not it's not
nowhere does s say that you know you
have to look at the minimum standards
set forth in 306 42 or whatever follow
up yes so then now taking that
that those pots I guess for lack of a
better word we're focused on the
performance-based accountability plan
correct so is there still in place the
mechanisms for schools to submit their
action plans is there corrective action
are they still labeled CSI and TSI I
mean is there technical so assistance R
does that part of the plan still exist
all under the federal absolutely that
just stays there um okay I'm not sure
and I think this is one of the things
that's confusing and I think we should
probably use better terminology or
different terminology is like I guess
right now under the law we have state
CSI schools and we have Federal CSI
schools we should I think the um there
should be a different well different
different terminology if they're going
to have different measurements and I
think one of the bills um used the word
State underperforming schools and that
so maybe we switch to that and then so
we have the whole federal system over
here we have the whole state system over
here and so we can
actually then then have the corrective
action plans all all of that work the
technical assistance under the state
side of things separate from the federal
side of
things we've been trying to work towards
this for years uh there was always the
issue of our high schools many many of
the high schools never received a title
$1 they they were received maybe within
that District For A Grade School uh so
then you had one maybe high school or
two high schools that are on that in uh
report needing support and they were
saying wow we have two really you know
failing high schools in the state that
was not necessarily the case we only had
two that were receiving Title One monies
that were perceived by the state as
being low there were others and so then
we went to the direction maybe this
accountability system needs to measure
all high schools or all schools in the
state which it should and that's I think
the struggle that we're you we're after
right now and that's a great example I
mean that that gra that that right there
is I mean it's a one of many many issues
that we have but that is a very
describable um understandable example
yeah so look going down through this the
we're still in uh Roman 2 there uh and
and sliding towards the other ones of
Roman 3 but are there any more uh
questions about Roman 1 or two I would
like to move on
here yes
representa no represent Damon thank you
Mr chair so I have a question going back
to representative Luna's
topic it on uh Ed the members of a
public interest group so is there a
definition of what a public interest
group Group
is because I have reservations about how
open-ended that
sounds like can an individual form a
public interest group that wants to
advocate for
some some particular aspect of education
and invite themselves to be part of this
so I would also think that the
commissioner the governor and the task
force would use Prudence when appointing
people to this commit
and so understanding
everybody's um backgrounds and expertise
and how they're going to be able to
dedicate their time and resources to
this task force are all things that the
department and the group of people doing
the appointing will understand um so it
I certainly I think anybody's able to
apply to be part of this task force but
we the legislature the department need
to make sure that they're appointing the
best available
people just yesterday we had the
Professional Standards Board we were
talking about and we were talking about
how Career Technical education wanted to
have some folks from the business
community on there seeing that they want
to have some impact as far as what that
outcome's going to be uh I don't see the
business Community used to be in the old
legislation for this task force right
here but they're not but they would come
underneath those other interested groups
they're they're not you know an
association it could be just somebody
coming out of you know one of our
manufacturing plants here that's has a
real strong interest in seeing that we
want kids coming out with these skills
and how you're going to measure those
skills by test or are you going to
measure it by application of the
skill I'll pause yeah yes represent
Tanner I mean so and I just want to to
representative Damon's point I mean if
you want to change that terminology we
perfectly happy with that we wanted to
make sure that we felt we had the
flexibility if we had a really high
quality group that came forward to the
department that wanted to participation
participate on it that we didn't limit
that and we obviously cannot list every
public interest group that exists in the
state or we have legislation as long as
this book so yeah represent Tanner thank
you um I think somebody from
representing special education should be
on that committee um because of the real
specific way that they're going to be
dealing with assessment um I also feel
that um we should have some of the
people appointed by different groups for
example the school boards Association
and then approved by the task force and
the commissioner I I just I want to get
away from political appointments as much
as possible on this if we're really
going to do it and lastly I totally
agree with you that you need at least
one or two experts on testing to to be
on that committee absolutely yeah
absolutely and there's there's a lot of
groups out there for example we used to
have a man that was sitting here all the
time years ago his name was Mark
Joyce and you know Mark he'd be a super
person on on a group like this Dr Joyce
and his family were all Educators from
Niger Falls area but he came to this
state and he was outstanding and he
oftentimes wrote Our statutes for us I I
worked with the mark for years myself
and I agree and that's partially why we
wanted to other educational experts
because somebody like Mark is not
working in a public school he's not
working for nhsa right now but we could
certainly now he's probably very happy
in Florida and not I think not wanting
to be sitting in this room because he
did that for many years but but people
like that that's exactly why we left it
open ended so yeah he and I were born in
the same
hospital within the same year at Niger
Falls County Hospital that's pretty
crazy yeah yeah it's a crazy world rep
Miler uh thank you Mr chair I have a
question on item e in the list here it
says the department shall advise
facilitate and support the task force is
this position a non-voting member or
just merely an advising member because I
would assume that members of the task
force are going to have to take some
perhaps some votes on issues ETC and so
the question I have is whether or not
the intent uh and E is for them to be a
voting member or merely an advise and
Technical Support merely advise and
Technical Support okay so that I think
that's an issue then should be clarified
we should put in parentheses technical
support or advising yeah like we do with
Jeff beards or what we do with Steve
applebe right exactly thank thank you
for the clarification thank good point
let's go on to item
Roman three on the the task force side
because is Roman two on the other side
pass Force shall have these following
duties any any issues with
that identify performance criteria and
measurements
Etc yes so I think I think you mentioned
this earlier what about the
organizational aspects of the task
force as being one of the first duties
that they well I think that's what we
have to identify who's going to be the
chair and how do you I thought we had
that documented as something we have to
amend yeah so calling the who's going to
call the first meeting then the First
Act is to elect a chair yeah unless it's
the first name person is the chair or
what you know it could be yeah I mean
whatever that whole thing we got to
resolve that that be done I think easily
yeah but I think that needs to be in the
even though it wasn't in the 2020
statute I think um I think that's
important um uh also that um that that
meetings will be conducted in public
duly noticed uh whether there's going to
be public comment period um in those
meetings you know so the organizational
structure is important then something
that came up on our school funding
commission although the pandemic um it
got swept away by uh by the p mic was um
whether um non-legislative members I
know and there aren't legislative
members on that uh would be would
receive mileage particularly if they're
coming from you know parts of the state
that are 100 miles away I noticed the
legislative members were not on this
right here there are no legisl they were
before were wants to be on that no so
they were before but the reason we put
that out is because we wanted to bring
it to the oversight committee and so we
really were kind of putting everything
back on the power of the oversight
committee um and that's that's like
oversight committee has the ultimate
kind of like where they're bringing this
group is bringing the results of that
and that's why we took them off yeah so
I think I think that's a reasonable way
to engage the legislative members um on
this but but even without legisl even if
there's no legislative members on here I
think providing some mileage
consideration or something like that
realistically this is my personal
opinion um realistically mileage and
potentially siphons would be really
helpful but the department didn't want
to put something that has a um a fiscal
note forward honestly because we wanted
to get done we are expecting these
people to be educational experts to take
time their probably personal time to do
this work it would be great if we could
pay a nominal stien to
to show people we at least appreciate
their time and appreciate and and um
efforts towards this so but I don't know
that that's that's not something the
department ever does and so I just want
to kind of put that out there um didn't
go to
well we know the department has Deep
Pockets so oh yeah very deep um the the
commissioner and the olw or design shall
be the chairman that was in Laine so uh
we want to really work that out who's
going to be the chair let's move on down
to the this area three here the task
force and the following duties
um any issues there so we can march on
down
further how about Roman 4 the task force
shall develop informance based scoring
system so and um actually and just let
me read the the current
law and Senate Bill 378 discuss how the
PB pbass shall be based on data and
indicators current law references data
and indicators the indicators that
you're
referencing are on page 564
the delivery of an adequate education
that's where you I think you've probably
lifted number number of these indicators
and put in
here
the I noticed if you can look on 5 564
and 565 you can see those indicators and
a number of those indicators sort of are
have been integrated
in can you speak to that first yeah well
so one thing I just just want to point
out because representative Bel brought
this up last time and we was talking
about using only the best available
accountability system that is actually a
typo we went back and we looked at the
original legislation that Nate and I had
typed up and it it was um it it had just
got messed up in the track changes so
that I know you had lots of questions
about it and we were kind of confused
about it too what it meant it literally
is a typo so using only the best
available accountability system can be
struck out so it would say the task
force shall develop a performance-based
accounting system using only the best
available data indicators which are
already available um and provided to the
department so that's what the existing
law says that's what the old law says
there was a typo and that's why we
couldn't figure out what it was supposed
to mean um so so yes the majority of it
is from the existing law slthe old plan
um the existing law for some reason
lists out all of the College and Career
Readiness indicators like they're all
separate things but it's actually one
measurement so um The College and Career
Readiness indicator is a current plan is
a current indicator in the existing plan
and then there is 11 I believe TW or 11
or 12 subcategories of it which are
enumerated in current law but it's not
very clear from the current law that
they are actually subcategories of the
College and Career Readiness indicators
and so that's why we um grouped them all
into the College and Career Readiness
indicators as defined by the saf
plan yes represent tal um I didn't I
don't notice that growth is in this and
I think growth was in the Essa plan and
also very I think it's very key um and
I'm not quite sure how you would put it
in but I know with Competency Based
education sometimes they have to they
people take the competency several times
or whether there you know there's a
growth over that period of time and and
that to me seems to be one of the things
that should be an indicator um and and
that's mostly encompassed by performance
on the state assessment because we
usually typically measure growth and
performance um sorry growth and
achievement under performance um but if
we needed to further enumerate that we
could I think that opens up a another
door here are we talking about a compeny
based assessment or are we talking about
a performance-based assessment we're
talking about the state assessment
defined under RSA 193c so which is it
it's a compet
it's it's neither of those it's just the
state assessment it's not it's not a
performance basis it's so Mr CH just in
in this whole area where you know
looking at the the potential you know
indicators and and how to how to you
know develop a a pbass based on what
information is there a reason why why
the task force would be limited only to
data that's currently being collected by
the department or could the task force
suggest as as we've done in House Bill
1586 which is an interim study as well
as in House Bill 1680 from a couple
years ago uh other indicators that the
Department's currently not collecting
that could be used to help measure the
um the uh the outcomes of a um of a of a
school district so we use that
terminology because that's what's in in
existing law if the committee wanted to
expand that I think you certainly could
um we just need to make sure that we
have a a way of collecting it and that
it's I I think we just need to be
careful how much we're expanding on the
data no no that's fine but I mean giving
giving the task force a little bit of um
you know leeway to to to maybe suggest
you know an indicator that the task
force feels has value that currently is
not being um being collected I mean one
that we talked about on the the um
higher ed task force was the um uh
information about the number of students
that um graduate from high school and
matriculate to a two or four year or
postsecondary um and how it's being
collected Now versus how it could be you
know collected and I think you were very
interested in that uh um you know yeah
yeah so that's ex existing law and I
think so certainly feel free to change
it but we didn't want to expand much
more than so I mean this is really a
sort of a copy from existing law um I
mean we already do have the other
metrics and so I think that um if if
there was another metric that you guys
determined and you could certainly
it's just a reminder this will
ultimately determ this will ultimately
result in something that would need to
be written in law right and so you could
certainly strike that out or you know
say the department will collect X Y and
Z from schools but this task force is
going to hopefully come up with
something that will be a new RSA 193
whatever c yeah and and I I hope the
task force would have the flexibility to
be able to look at maybe more you know
additional indicators that maybe were
difficult or impossible to collect 10
years ago but but now um can be
collected either by by the department
directly from the districts or through
or by the department through uh through
a third party like the what what was the
one that we Clearing House the Clearing
House exactly so so thanks represent
cascaden then represent my um okay just
to try to move move on from part four
but looking at part
four um you just said something about a
a type a typo so I'm still thinking part
four is going to replace part
three and maybe that first sentence is
Chang to the task force shell develop um
I don't know maybe maybe you're Crossing
out scoring
system but I don't know that there's a
need to list all of those if you just
reference a to O the 15 indicators in
the
law and it sounds like you want to add
or we want to add that last piece that's
recommended other metrics as determined
by the task force so we're maintaining a
to O that's in current law and adding
other metrics as determined by the tax
Force so it leaves it open-ended should
there be something else but it's listed
here as if it's new but it really isn't
that's true the only the issue with it
being enumerated and current law right
now is if there are changes to the Essa
plan they're not Incorporated in current
law and we do feel like those college
and Readiness indicators really need to
be look like we think that is an
important indicator in the Essa plan
that should be looked at and so that's
the it it it's challenging if we have a
list right here and then a list over
here that don't equal and so that's why
we were saying get rid of the
individuals that are numerated and then
just refer back to the sa plan for for
the College and Career because College
and Career indicators are and a
requirement of the SAA plan but they're
not listed in this plan they're not so
it's it's just under C so it says
College and Career Readiness indicators
aligned to the New Hampshire
Consolidated state plan okay so you
could just so you just use C right
instead in addition to a to O um yeah
because in the existing law yeah that's
right so we're adding two more to the
original list in the law
right to point out the College and
Career Readiness indicators because
those are a SE list and they're also in
the federal
plan yeah so we're in the current law
we're kind of Crossing out
um D E F G H I
J K
L yeah those ones were crossing out in
the current law in the current law can
you repeat that please uh so in the
current law it is um d e f g h i I J K L
those are the those are the some of but
not all of the Essa um the college
readiness indicators in the plan what
about m m through o
um so those are not um indicators of the
Essa plan though I mean sorry those are
not college and indicators um but
see you have it as G here and M there
are the same
thing G here so yes right so we're
continuing to include that but but so
we're we're leaving G yes we're leaving
G that's why we're just the the middle
ones are essentially getting
Consolidated up to the
indicators so we're
consolidating D to L because they're all
College and Career Readiness indicators
correct correct and they're in the
federal plan correct okay so then we
still need m n and
O although that would be reclassified
because you're compressing a whole bunch
and you're adding other metrics as
determined by the task force well I
think you know the department really
wanted to have a conversation too to say
like you know so are those things truly
a measure of an adequate education as
teacher administrative turnover rates
actually an indicator of if you're
providing an adequate education or is
that something that you should be
looking at relative to the overall
performance of an education system which
are different same with the fasta
completion okay so would that be
something the task force would continue
to discuss absolutely the other metrics
as determined by the task force because
we could be splitting here here I think
we're splitting here but I'm also real
concerned where you are I'm concerned
I'm sure represent Cornell is same what
about F right what about the Creer of
technical Education certification and
outcomes there which we're trying to
grow that that program we know we have
to we should be tracking it f is
encompassed in in uh the College and
Career Readiness indicators so in the S
plan that's we're not getting rid of it
it's one I like it when it's spelled
right out Career Technical education
okay well Career and Technical education
so is it do we want to talk about I
maybe we need another category that
specifically talks about Career and
Technical education and participation in
career and Tech education so is it
participation is it you know what is
that I think I think maybe that's a
whole different category but then also
also though my question is is is that a
measurement of somebody is receiving an
adequate education well I would think so
the achievement scores that kids coming
out of CTE are higher than they are
coming out of high schools but we're
already looking at achievement scores
for measurement of out education yeah
yeah okay um so CTE is extremely
important but again we have to think
those centers are not in every single
high school so they're Regional centers
as you know and I think College and
Career indicators would cover
some work or achievement within a Career
and Technical Ed Center but if you're
looking at a real small high school okay
let's take Pittsburgh has eight kids
probably in that senior class and out of
those eight
kids maybe half of them are going to
college and half are not and none of
them are interested in going over to
Canan C
or
toook so now you have no kids in a
particular High School participating in
a CTE program just by design that could
happen what I don't know any any small
high school that has to travel to a
center and I I worry that if we put CTE
in as one of the
criteria so Mr it should be under
College and Career Readiness anyways why
you could put such as but not limited to
Career Technical education but I think
it's also spelling out that we have a
weakness in our CTE program in this
state a definite weakness and when we
have approximately 20% of the kids not
attending because they're an ascending
School
correct and the 80% are in those schools
which have it internally and some high
schools require that all students take
CT a CT course for graduation
requirement in some schools with a CTE
Center don't require credit y for
graduation right so so I mean that's
another isn't this more task force
conversation though task I think it is
let's let's just vote that they'll have
a task force if this is all task
force issue then you should say
reference this statutory language 193 E3
just reference ROM was stated by
represent Cas except except having
having some flexibility to uh to
consider um new indicators that
currently aren't being collected by the
department and that would also be task
force discussion that that oh that
indicator doesn't make sense that
indicator does make sense you keep H
there in and put to reference the
current statute Cho as yeah as long as
as long as there's flexibility to have a
conversation in the task task force with
members of the department to consider uh
other factors and the department could
could come back and say yeah we can
collect that or we can find that
information or there's no way we'll ever
get that information that's impossible
to collect and then that's all task
force
consideration okay are we good Roman for
repres
yeah
um mine is a more of a high level
question I guess and that is you you've
got these eight
indicators and you say a Performance
Based scoring
system how does that work so Performance
Based is basically you're you're looking
at that's what we have right now it's
the Performance Based accountability
system that's the actual name and so
you're looking at how the school's
performance on the various different
indicators are or how the schools are
performing on the various different
indicators and then doing some sort of
rank ordering or some sort of some sort
of something that's exactly what we need
to figure out like how are you doing
that measurement um and then how are you
determining if schools are performing as
they they're supposed to be doing to
Prov like is the performance of the
school indicating that the school is
providing an adequate education as
opposed to the other side of what which
is inputs like so these are things that
the state has said you're supposed to do
yes the you're doing all of these things
through ibass like you are offering you
know reading math blah blah blah blah
all of the courses and then but for some
reason the kids are not performing
through the other metrics and so that's
that's how the two systems work together
so one is looking at what are you
providing and then the other side is how
are you you actually doing and so the
assessment is the majority of the
measurement of that but it's also
potentially participation in the career
and tech ed education indicators it's
the attendance rate so if a school say
had attendance rates of 20% are we is
that is that school providing an
adequate education that's exactly what
we need to do we need to look at these
different indicators and say what is an
indicator of of a school providing an
adequate education and then s setting
ranges too like what is the approp rate
range so is it 20% attendance rate is it
80% attendance rate or do we care if the
school has 0% attendance rate but for
some reason 95% of their kids are
proficient on the assessment so it's
it's looking at those different
indicators and measurements and and
working through exactly that so I'm
going try to get this down to real basic
here let's take a tendance rate is there
a 1 to five just as an example do that
is I'm looking for what the metrics is
that you're looking at so on that one
category let's say attendance y one to
five five being terrific one being four
if somebody comes in at 20% of
attendance rate do they get a rank of
one that goes into some kind of a
calculation so so right now yes I mean
that's that's exactly how the federal
accountability system works attendance
rate isn't but that's we look at how
they're performing and we say different
um performance this equals a one that
equals a two that equals a three and we
we and then we rank all of the schools
against each other and we look at the
different levels and and so that's
something that we need to determine for
this exactly like which ones of these
and where they should be measured and
what the appropriate we need to set what
the appropriate level is for each one of
these indicators that and that's what
the department does that's what the
accountability team does so once once
you have the metrics identified and you
go through each school and you look at
the indicators then does the school get
kind of a total score yes and then they
go back and say okay here's what here's
what determined that total score yes and
you can see where we're doing well where
we need to improve Etc so that's that's
what the system does yes that's and
that's what our existing system the
fallacy though to that whole system is
we're letting the federal government
waged the dog and and now that's where
I've had this issue with graduation the
69% level are we going to go by that
level or are we going to go by a 90%
that we are right we're let that 69% wag
us and that that to me is that's always
been the issue that we are a state that
prides our in being better than the rest
of the states but we're holding oursel
to the bar established by those lower
States right and that's the issue with
having the two systems tie together and
the graduation rate is a great example
yeah so how do we get around that
because I'm still oppositional to this
69% even though we said okay do it no we
get way we get around it by saying
graduation rates and we the task force
says any school that has a graduation
rate of less than 80% is not providing
an adequate education bam I mean that's
what we do and that's exactly why we
need State accountability versus Federal
account and I'm not saying that 80% is
the right I'm just s a random number so
I just want to say that that's not what
the Department's advocating for but
that's exactly why we need a state
accountability system because a because
we're saying like what we're trying to
measure is if a school is providing an
adequate education which is very
different what than does the federal
government recognize kids to graduate in
5 years instead of four years no the
federal government doesn't and so and
that's also when we're talking about
kids that get a high set that's not
recognized in the federal graduation
rate and maybe we want to have those
conversations maybe we want to have a
state defined graduation rate does we
say four or five years and maybe we want
to say we also want to do other college
completion so we want to do a GED or a
high set and include that um that very
well might be part of what the
conversation is and these are great
questions for the task force so rson
Damon thank you so I'm still in that
section four and the statute on page 64
with the list of indicators says shall
include
the um proposed task force language says
may include the
indicators if we think they're all
important why would they be optional
so the shall include right now is
current currently aligned to law this
section of curtain law is not going away
until this task force hopefully comes up
with a new indicator list and probably
we'll say shall and then bring it
forward and we rewrite the current law
but we're saying hey task force look at
at least these things like you need to
look at these things I me if you want to
change it to a may you certainly could
but no it says may already I mean sorry
I shall you certainly could but um but
we're trying to say task course this is
what we want you to do this is what you
want you to look at look at at least
these things so so I think it should say
sh thank you for your
answer yes represent Tanner so are there
going to be like hybrid schools some
that do Competency Based or is this for
everybody now so everybody's going to
one system everybody already is on one
system the definition of adequate
education is Law and what schools are
supposed to be providing and it doesn't
matter if they're hybrid or whatever
this is all public district schools are
supposed to be providing adequate
education as defined by RSA 193e and
then we are supposed to we the
Department of Education are supposed to
measure through the input based and the
performance-based accountability system
whether those schools are actually in
fact providing an adequate education but
that's what I mean you have you have two
measurements performance-based and
correct so does does a school get rate
it on one or the other or they rate it
on both both that's what the law
requires and this is not changing that
we changed that it's it's not for
example input based you could have
accreditation and that would satisfy
your input yeah but uh we wanted
performance too so we said both I think
we did that a couple years back 2020 so
Al along those same lines though when
when um when looking at um indicators uh
to to that feed into the pbass and and
whether a a school district is or school
is providing an adequate education does
the department currently collect for
lack of a better term other mitigating
factors that might contribute for to um
um to to the performance um of um of you
know student outcomes whe you know for
for example one that might contribute to
low attendance might be um you know uh a
high number of students with with you
know fragile medical conditions or
something like that or one that might
might contribute to to uh
other you know lower performance might
be um you know high percentage of free
and reduced price lunch or or families
that live in poverty well I mean so I
mean we certain I guess it it depends on
what you want to as I said no too
quickly so we absolutely we have number
of kids that are free roduced we have
number of kids English language Learners
that are special education we have kids
that are participating in CTE programs
we have expens expulsion and suspension
rates we have attendance rates so some
of those could certainly be um used um
but to your point before there might be
other ones that the Department's not
collecting um that we may or may not
have the ability to collect and and in
the in the current pbass do are those
mitigating factors considered in the in
the accountability um formula I guess so
in the current pbass system which is
aligned to the federal system we look at
the performance of subgroups and so we
do look at performance of English
language Lear learners compared to the
total population or English or special
education towards that and that is one
of the um things that could categorize
you as a ATS or a CSI School CSI is the
performance of the whole school ATS is
the performance of a certain subgroup
okay great thank you okay let's get on
to the next R well because we have you
know a real important ones coming up and
cl to this one this this is the one I
think that's going to generate all the
concern and questioning you know beyond
where we've been so we're we're looking
at at
this I I'm looking at Roman five on
let's see excuse me no I'm going looking
at Roman four on our side the current
law verse five on that law and I guess
the question we're going to have
is on the Roman four side where current
law after the report is approved by the
Legislative oversight
committee that approval is taken away
from legis ative oversight now there's
no approval given now in this new
process recommendation things come for
consultation but there's no approval so
the this goes back to my point before
the department would need a new law
written so the the plan would come to
the legislature to actually write a new
perform so I think so and I just noticed
something and this was it was not
supposed to be I gotta make sure it's
not it was not supposed to be repeal and
rep what I need to C
E3
C how did 266 get through them so no no
so
so following duties blah blah blah blah
blah blah so this is not repeal and
replace the existing accountability
system the existing accountability
system is B and it's still there in law
um and the department would still
continue to operate the existing
accountability system until we had a new
accountability system so this group
would bring forward a plan to you all
and you say that's a great plan or
that's a terrible plan and somebody on
this probably table has to sponsor a new
new law that would replace RSA 193 EB e
e3b um which would then rep talk about
the entire accountability system so the
department doesn't just have the like
doesn't have the authority to go
Implement its own accountability system
it's it's in law and so that's why the
oversight committee would we thought was
the appropriate place to say all right
we we as the oversight committee will
develop a bill or we won't develop a
bill and what this reminds me it's just
like the fox overlooking the hen
house okay who's the fox that oversight
committee the department yeah yeah well
were you taking
where you're basically say taking when
this report's submitted all approval
away from the legislative oversight
committee and you don't have it's
basically not going to be submitted to
this board of education the oversight
committee yes but the findings and
recommendations is not saying what
they're supposed to do are they supposed
to approve this is the board going to
approve it they can't approve it until
it becomes law no the and the board
can't do anything about it I mean the
board doesn't have legis is not going to
prove something until it's gone through
legislative oversight right it's got to
go through the law yeah I I guess I'm
confused because I mean the department
doesn't have the ability to do anything
without a law this has to result in a
law yeah that would change the
performance Val or we just keep the
existing accountability system which we
would continue to run until there's a
new law so if the report comes back for
approval recommendations and then
approval from the oversight committee
it's going to make it a lot easier for a
committee like this to sit down and not
have to Wade through what we're doing
right now all over again when it's been
done through the oversight committee and
that's the purpose of that committee so
right and I think that's what the depart
that the report shall be submitted to
the the the oversight committee that's I
think what the department was trying to
do that's why we would submit it to the
oversight committee so I guess I'm
confused or are you saying that that is
not enough or this is it it the gets
submitted to the board of education and
the oversight committee and it should
say gets com submitted to the oversight
committee before it goes to the State
Board of Education absolutely it's just
an informational item because the 306s
should have gone to an oversight the
legislative committee before it went to
the State Board of
Education because that's that's not
that's a mandate for the State Board
yeah minimum standards we don't have
that Authority yet and I want to say
that's Ru making this is not Ru making
this would need a
law so I guess I I guess I'm I'm
confused because I I think this is
saying that it's going to go to the
oversight committee so are you saying
this doesn't say that clear enough or I
mean I certainly you can amend however
you want but to to me this says it's
going to go to the oversight
committee no it doesn't say prior to it
just
says um but the task force can't create
a PS would have to
be you I think what I heard you say
though Kaitlin is that the
recommendations for the task force if
they were to take effect would have to
be put into statute first exactly so it
would have to pass through assuming this
committee or
commit that is responsible for Education
yes and so maybe do we need to add
another sentence that somebody will
write a law about it or I I don't know I
yeah something in between five and six
Roman 5 and six yes because in six
you're advis it's it's ad in but there's
no approval coming the the legislative
oversight committee is almost like an
afterthought
here um and that I'm certainly like
willing to have you change it however
you want so this right now saying the
Department is supposed to implement
pbass and that's what it's saying
Department supposed to implement pbass
as defined by RSA 193 E2 so right now R
this bill right here does not touch RSA
193 E2 so so until RSA 193 E2 is changed
the department will continue to
implement the existing pbass system and
then if then while then when the report
is prepared if then you guys want to
write a new RSA 1932 the department will
Implement that too represent Celli but
this isn't saying the department will
Implement whatever the task for this
that's certainly not what this is saying
because the task force cannot write a
law right and and also in terms of
approval what happens if the legislative
oversight committee does not quote
unquote
approve what the task force comes in up
with I think instead what we're saying
is that um the legislative oversight
committee shall recommend uh put forward
recommendations for future legislation
after review of the task force findings
if you think that makes it more clear to
that's I'm perfectly fine with that I
mean I think that'd be helpful if we
told the task force to actually do
something with it cuz you're right I
mean task force could do nothing with it
and then we Department goes around and
begs in you know each one of you guys to
put in a bill for us like we've done
with this and and some of the other
proposals but yeah I mean to get the
ultimate goal is to get something in law
that the department can Implement that's
really what we're trying to do here
so right you're starting to take the
department out of it and you're putting
it in the hands of the task
force now you're I I I see the
legislative oversight committee sort of
being put to the side too and then yes
you're going to advise the the
legislature later we need legislation I
think that there should be more contact
with the oversight committee with
specific terminology saying you shall
recommend and you know or get some kind
of recommendation out of the oversight
committee on this before we go any
further I I'm fine with that I mean I
didn't think we needed to tell the
committee to act but I think that's
perfect ly fine that works out better
for the Department okay represent Tanner
maybe that was um one of the purposes of
having a legislator on the task force is
that that legislator could be from the
oversight committee so that as the the
whole thing is developing the task force
has input or the oversight committee has
input you know I I I can go either way
on that but I know that the the the
working group we put together just the
other day when we're talking about
Capital Improvements for CTE doesn't
have any legislators on it I think we
can get what we want to have on there
how many people here have a strong
strong strong background in test and
measurement you can go through the
statistics and all that and the bell
curve and all that represent cascaden
probably has some but as as an
administrator I that was not necessarily
my bailey Wick it it's it's so we need
people on there the going to have some
understanding of what we want to come
out with and something that has some
Merit and and can be measurable and as
we've said before in legislation
something that's
objective just as a followup what I'm
saying is that instead of having the
task force meet over here and then all
of a sudden put their report on the
legislative oversight committee if you
had a repres they don't even have to be
voting but a representative from the
legislative oversight committee that
meets with the task force that sees
what's happening that can put some input
back and forth whether legislation would
be um practical or doable or enforceable
or however you want to do it I just
think my my whole thought was just that
they're in on the
process I I I
I I don't have any feeling one way or
the other on this seeing that I feel
that this is really an executive body
responsibility but what they want to put
in laws our responsibility we should
have the oversight of what is
designed so I think that when we try to
get down into the weed sometimes we get
ourselves so spread so thinly for 100
bucks a year I so and so the department
can certainly take on this work right so
we we tried with 266 and we tried to do
it under advisement with a group of
superintendents we had a group of
superintendents come to the department
and work with us on that legislation but
we just couldn't get there with that
bill because there were so many
questions that came up and the questions
were like well shouldn't you be
considering this and that and the other
indicators and so when we were trying to
put forward we felt were truly technical
fixes with the existing law that's when
we got derailed with the conversations
of why are you not concluding CTE why is
the graduation 67% and that's those
those were the things that were in the
existing law and
so Nate and I took that into advisement
and we said all right we need we need to
add technical Corrections and fixes to
the existing law so we can implement it
and do our jobs that we're supposed to
be doing but then two clearly the
legislature has additional concerns with
the performance-based accountability
system which were addressed in this room
and so we really need to do a deeper
dive into that and that's why we thought
a task force was the best thing to
do I don't I I mean to be perfectly
honest I'm a little frustrated with this
because the department really did try
Nate and I are sitting in our offices in
the basement come over and see us in the
basement and we're trying to put
together the accountability system and
make it work and trying to teach the
schools on what they have to be
submitting and why they have to be
submitting it and then trying to explain
to schools well if we determine you as a
CSI school for the state accountability
purposes it doesn't matter how well
you're doing you're just in the bottom
5% and that's just and that's that and
there's also no ties into an adequate
education and also if you're not a title
one in school there's nothing we can do
to to help you and these are the
challenges that we're trying to do and
then also trying to like read through
this law in just in order and try to say
all right here's step one here's step
two but Step One is on this page step
two is 30 pages here step seven is back
the beginning of the book that these are
challenges that we're doing and and so
that's what we tried to do the first
time we got very derailed and we're
saying all right well maybe we
overstepped our kind of our skis on this
one and we are trying to pull it back
and say the legislature wanted us to to
really talk about this in a um to really
talk about the entire system and that's
why we said like let's at least try to
do a task force then and and let let's
let's revisit the entire system rather
than just the technical fixes and
Corrections and and to be honest when we
brought that group of superintendents in
they sat with this and they're like some
of them said hey let's look at CTE let's
look at that and they said that put that
in your parking lot those are great
ideas but what we're trying to do is
technical Corrections and fixes to that
law so let's get it through the
technical Corrections fixed and then
improve it and that's what we had in
planned so with 266 our plan was let's
do the technical Corrections and then
let's expand the system now so we
scrapped all of that and our back to
this idea so if if you have a a better
idea so if you have a better idea please
tell us because because we're trying to
do what is in this very large book and
we're really stumbling through it and
and we we need help is really we share
your frustration when we're dealing with
193 c e and H right and it's convoluted
it's a mess and it's
disjointed uh I you know I think what
you got is is a framework here which can
work I think there's a few areas we've
mentioned where tweaks to it could occur
but in looking at how we're going to
move forward we got to have a plan to
doing that and what you've offered us is
the only solid plan um and I get
frustrated with our own legislature you
know we're having a pretty good
discussion here I don't know what Happ
on the other side of that wall this is a
great discussion I mean and I wish we
actually had time for some of these more
detailed discussions because it would be
like a lot of these sections a lot we
would really like to clean up and and I
don't know if maybe it's a better of a
summer discussion or something like that
too like where we can really get into
some of these weeds but well then you
have to probably rediscussed with a new
committee and different bium represent
cascaden so the bottom line is you know
that's why they say don't give anything
to the politicians because they get
nothing done I think that we should
support getting a task force and letting
them do their work we're going to have
the oversight
anyway but they need to have the
leverage of that task force to be able
to get into the nuts and bolts of this
to try to start aligning things because
at the same time they can't put
everything on hold in the districts cuz
the districts are still going to be all
account accountable for all this
stuff but I think we need to move off
the tables okay they need a task force
get it organized and let the task force
do their work and then let's get
something
done sorry I'm a little I'm I'm a
checklist just drives me crazy I think I
think we're recognizing something has to
be done and this is a process which
should work with a few you know who's
going to be chair we can do that stuff
get it in there uh but uh
I I concur with you um we need to do
something here it's it's it's not
working the way it is right now and I I
think part of that's not working is
there was an original task force and for
some reason the part probably part of
that we took it out of Law and we're
saying oh no that really was important
and there was a need for that
so I mean it'd be easier without a task
force but then you're letting Nate and I
make all the decisions which is scary um
but because the task force is going to
take a lot of time and resources of the
department but we also feel like by
doing the task force that will get it
done right and correctly and that will
like allow the stakeholders to be
engaged and involved and and whatnot so
yeah are there further questions from
the committee yes represent dry is there
an end date for this task task force um
yes yes September 25
yeah and that's going to be hard to get
done that's going to be hard but but it
needs to get done pretty so okay yes so
I'm I'm just looking at that report
should be submitted annually this is on
page five of the draft there to the by
July 1st to the task force the Board of
Ed and the oversight committee so that
seems to me to be in perpetuity so
that's annually that's the um that's the
results of the performance so that's
basically who did how who performed what
on the performance- based accountability
system okay but it's going to the task
force doesn't the task force um dissolve
eventually um I we so we don't Envision
the task force to disolving the our
federal task force that we have right
now doesn't dissolve we have a group of
superintendents mostly um that are that
review it we meet I think four times a
year um and they advise us and we so we
try to meet before assessment season
after assessment season and then and in
the summer and then just once in the
fall just to kind of give everybody's
Minds around everything and that we're
we're continuously look looking at the
federal Essa plan we're looking at you
know school's ability to perform like
one of the things that we looked at oh I
I guess I was going to say recently but
not maybe two years ago at this point
was um the performance on the widda
system and we said maybe the indicators
that we determined were not appropriate
and we went back and we looked at that
and we then asked the US Department the
task force reviewed the scores the
performance of the schools other metrics
nationally and determined that what we
had said in our plan our Essa plan
wasn't appropriate for
um the WID assessment and we went back
and modified our state plan to change
the um score that we were using to
determine proficiency for the English
language so it it is something that need
to continuously happen to um to because
this is growing this is
changing you know you changed the
definition for an adequate education
because you add things like personal
literacy in and so the other one that
when maybe the original pbass was
determined that wasn't something so the
task force would need to say all right
well how do we make Ure that the school
is providing providing an adequate
education and appropriately measuring
its performance of providing P personal
finance financial literacy and so that's
what the task force would need to do and
and it doesn't go away oh okay could I
follow yes okay because when I Envision
a task force it has a task it does the
task it gets this thing that it that
this pbass assessment and passes it on
but this is actually going to continue
it's going to be many tasks Force
correct well I mean because the law is
always changing so if you were going to
say you're never going to change the
definition of adequate education ever
again the task force could probably
dissolve but because it's constantly
changing because assessments are
constantly changing because everything
is constantly changing the task force
needs to be there and it's it's a really
an advisory group of practitioners um
that help the department because you
know the department has one
responsibility for implementing the
accountability systems the assessment M
and everything like that and then the
schools have a very different piece of
actually assessing the kids collecting
the data everything like that and so it
works together hand inand the department
can't do its work without the schools
and the schools can't do its work
without the department
so further questions of
Caitlyn did a good job thank you yeah
thanks for
coming well CIT we always appreciate
when you come from the Department
because you you you give us a a clear
picture whether we agree or not it's
always welcomed and and I know at least
from Nate and I and my other staff we
appreciate that time too because we at
least we do very important work at the
department mostly because you guys have
told us to do the work someplace in law
and we appreciate being able to discuss
the work we're doing and get the input
of the committee and so we always
appreciate these conversations I just
wish you had gotten that data an analyst
that we
I I wish we had as well but yeah next
budget right there's another banian
budget coming up sooner rather than
later so we we passed it unanimously out
of here it was killed in division
two or Finance not division two Finance
yep well thank you very much for coming
we're going to take a short break here
and I don't know if we should even start
addressing that other bill
yet you you you can have that was that's
an extra one that I
had pardon
me oh you have one in the
[Laughter]
office okay thank you for let's take um
let's discuss we had one other Bill
scheduled for review I don't know if we
have the time to do it before lunch or
we just take and have a lunch break now
yeah uh we don't have a great rush to
have to deal with it's not an early bill
so we have some time here y so let's
just take a break now come back at 1:00
when we're scheduled to go forward with
the other part of the ad do for today
and that's where we're looking at exing
some bills here um 378 32 526
339 uh obviously and looking that right
now I don't think we're prepared to EXA
378 we just talked that and there's
obviously some amending language 526
let's see school we haven't just Hut
talked that and and that leaves SB 339
are the Bills which we didn't do
yesterday we had two bills which we
didn't and both of those need work too
so is there any need for us to come back
this afternoon pardon me that's the
question yeah yeah I would say we're not
going to be acting on anything this
afternoon it's probably wi after this
conversation here we're not prepared to
go forward with
378 so with that I don't think we need
to come back this afternoon why would we
not do
339 well unless we're unless we're
prepared to go forward and discuss it no
not we we can't do it right now if if
we're going to come back at one o'clock
the only one we would do is possibly
this and anything we didn't do from
yesterday but it's not required to get
done immediately that's
right well well let's let's come let's
come back at one o'clock and discuss
that latter bill that we see there 339
339 we can also discuss
526 because we we can open up an exec
session and then have a discussion on it
and if we're not ready to go forward
with that as if we see amending language
needed we can you know put that off as
well but it's an opportunity to discuss
so we will come back at one
o'clock yes so are we waiting for an
amendment on Senate Bill 378 is that why
we can't act on that I think there were
working on we working on based upon what
we discussed today okay that's there are
some things we can add I think the
strength in the bill yeah so so Mr chair
four of us are going to work on that
Amendment we should work together on
that well I'll put together a
subcommittee okay to do that yeah yeah
yeah
yeah okay thank
you pardon
mees how much do they spend on
sb266 usually their heing only 10
minutes so they you know went above and
beyond yeah maybe we got more than we
expected thank you we'll meet at one
o'clock this part of the meeting is a
journ oh that's right someone's got I
forgot that I did
too I got car I do too I got my cheese
and crackers in the
car oh
boy
e
okay for everybody in the room what
we're going to do is before we go into
the exec session we're going to have a
quick caucus right
here so you can go outside and look at
everything you want to look out the
window at in another
room because we're going to go in a
caucus right
[Music]
now
yeah yeah there there's a Cornerstone to
that
build
e
committee I want to welcome all the
public to the meeting
here yeah and we have going around the
table here yeah representative p is here
uh representative broker's here
uh well I I'm seeing Mary Heath is just
a permanent member now yeah and there's
nobody going to my right so welcome
welcome all um for today uh we're going
to try to set some kind of record of
getting out of here and so I'm asking
that we only have discussion from the
maker of the bill or the motion and the
second if the second cares not to ditto
what
the what the uh maker of the motion said
so with that we're going to jump over
378 seeing that we had a good discussion
this morning and a work session on that
we know we're going to have to have some
amending language so we'll jump to the
next bill
SB
526 this is a bill relative to public
school facility condition assessment and
school building Aid grants for
temperature control and I Look
to represent beler for a motion thank
you Mr chair I would move itl is there a
second SEC second so we have a motion by
representative beler for to itl and
that's second by representative
cordelli represent beler thank you Mr
chair um so as you said this bill would
seek to establish um uh studies and look
to give grants for uh significantly
improved air conditioning systems in
schools but some significant concerns
were raised within this we're looking at
uh the cost there there's very intensive
studies that are mandated to be
conducted at all schools within this
bill um and there's also some frankly
unworkable Provisions it seems to me
when it comes to the requirement that a
classroom be entirely shutter
should the temperature fall to 59 f um
so for those reasons uh I would
recommend we don't move
forward cordelli uh thank you um I just
wanted to add on to that that um the air
quality is already in law um so there's
no need to duplicate that uh portion of
it and um we've heard heard
stories um from the chairman about his
days gone by with um
uh winter clothes on um Heating units in
his school and um the wonderful Aroma
later in the day and um I think we can
um get past those kinds of stories uh
these days without this
bill okay not seeing any further
discussion oh yes represent luno sure
thanks um I'm I'm also going to be uh
supporting the itl um motion on this and
um and and but um not because I don't
think that the intent of the bill isn't
spoton I do think I do think kids learn
better in an environment where where
where they're comfortable where they're
not sweating where they're not freezing
where they're not boiling uh and stuff
like that but I think there's also a lot
of things um within the school that can
be done to uh to improve student
outcomes one of which which I think
we've had a lot of conversation about
around this table and we'll have more
tomorrow is uh is making sure kids are
adequately fed and aren't hungry in
school and uh I think if the state's
going to be pushing money whether that's
done at the local level or from the
state level to uh to helping kids learn
better that would be the place to direct
uh direct our next dollar
thank you very much any further
discussion not see any Madam clerk would
you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative bogert yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 Y no
nay consent okay thank you very much
I'll remind the makers you have to get
the the committee report a blur in
before we leave today uh going on to the
next Bill SB
339 relative repealing the graduation
requirement re regarding free
application for federal student aid
FAFSA applications I Look to represent
Noble for a motion thank you Mr chair I
move itl second we have a motion made by
represent Noble that is itl and it's
second by representative
Miler represent Noble yep um we had a
house bill that also repeals FAFSA
um but um the difference is the house
bill added a Schoolboard policy for
providing information to families about
FAFSA so I think most of us probably
feel that that is a better bill because
we don't want to diminish the importance
of
ffsa further comments
wson all righty are you ready okay Madam
clerk would you please call the role
Vice chairman Deli yes representative
leus yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
bogert yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative C scadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 Ys no
Nays thank
you and we'll put it on
consent so that really takes care of the
bills we had in the docket for this
afternoon I hope the subs enjoyed
[Laughter]
it uh one one comment for everybody here
what our schedule looks like for next
week I've been informed I should not
schedule anything Monday because there's
a baseball game on that's
true important stuff so Tuesday we will
be
meeting and Tuesday we're going to start
at 9:30 and we're going to have two
hearings that that uh morning one of
them is on 219 Senate Bill 219 that's a
bill requiring mandatory reporting by
school districts of school expenses that
will go for 45 minutes then at 10 10:15
we'll pick up the second Bill and that's
379 that's relative to emergency action
plans for sports related um injuries so
219 379 that morning and then at uh
11:00 we have a subcommittee that's
going to be meeting and dealing with uh
378 and trying to work out an amendment
for that particular bill so um that's
all we'll be doing on
Tuesday Wednesday appears to be off and
Thursday we have session maybe maybe
depending upon what I guess they got
cranked up for well how much they have
received what time did you say 9:30 9:30
okay and and then uh on Friday we have
nothing there as
well so it looks like a pretty good
week so you know enjoy it and thank you
very much and see everybody
tomorrow
yeah
e